a las vegas woman is warning others
tonight she says she thought she was
getting a cosmetic procedure
but what she ended up was a medical
problem and she shared her personal
story with the i-team's vanessa murphy
vanessa investigated the issue and has
more on what others should be looking
out for
justine hill says she worked hard at
getting back in shape
after she gave birth four years ago i
just like i was so excited that i lost
so much weight because i lost almost
120 pounds but she felt like there was
one stubborn section so i wanted to
restore some volume back into
my buttocks area i had a lot of volume
loss so it was it almost looked like
cellulite but it was like very
big caverns of skin like a volume
missing so it was like it didn't have
any shape
no matter how hard it worked out she
tells the i-team she went to a woman who
she believed
was an aesthetician for injections in
her backside
and then it started getting very painful
she says the pain got worse
and she got an infection when she
reached out to that woman again to find
more about what she injected into her
body
the response macroline look up
information about the filler and you'll
find a horror story from abroad
after it was reportedly injected in
breasts
along with concerns about whether it
could interfere with
cancer screenings if anybody is using
macro lane here it is
not with the blessing of the fda and
it would also be really interesting on
how they would get their hands on it
because they're not supposed to sell it
here in the united states dr jeffrey
roth is a plastic surgeon
the problem that we plastic surgeons
have is people go to
folks that aren't plastic surgeons
aren't even doctors and we've had a
couple of deaths
even here in town dr roth who chairs a
committee at the nevada state medical
association also points to state law
a person shall not inject dermal or soft
tissue fillers unless the person is a
physician
or physician's assistant dentist
registered nurse
or podiatrist okay no one else
the other thing is is where can you
inject right
so there is also a statute involved
because people were getting injected at
the pools on the strip etc etc so it has
to be in a medical facility or doctor's
office
so here is where we keep the botox he
tells the i-team enforcement
needs to be stronger but here's the
botox that we have
and he says he's treated patients who
are trying to fix
problems like hills i had a long talk
with myself and i said we're going to
fix
what i messed up we're going to fix the
karma that i cause
but everything else i need to come up
with a natural
way to do this hill works in the
cosmetic industry
she says she started to feel a need to
look perfect
but now like it's a beautiful thing to
get old and
older you know to have scars to you know
my c-section scars that's my children
came out of me you know like
it's it's it's like each stretch mark
and each thing is like it's a story
she's concerned she may have scarring
from those bad injections
but she says lesson learned do your due
diligence
and just love yourself vanessa murphy 8
news now
now agencies like the nevada state board
of pharmacy the medical
board and law enforcement investigate
incidents involving
illegal substances such as microlane
injectables given by someone not
permitted to do so at a place
not allowed by nevada state law these
investigations are often complaint based